[Music]
all right so let's get into some more
science okay i love it some of us love
science here which hat is that this one
probably not right no i don't think
either one likes science i don't think
so either yeah slides not very popular
simon's gonna keep one of them alive too
that's true they both hate science let's
wear both of them there you go wow very
cool pretty cool uh who here knows how
to explain how heart works a heart a
human heart how all heart works or
hearts how it works blood flows through
pumps it out goes the rest of the body
you got a bunch of chambers yeah and a
story
continuous blood flow goes through the
heart pumps it up goes all the way up i
can tell you what i remember there's
four chambers
one of them is called aorta or some [ __ ]
i forgot yeah and then ventricle we got
a bunch of legislative judicial why does
eyes get so small when he's trying to
remember [ __ ] the one that's pumping
away is [ __ ] blue or some [ __ ] and
then it gets oxidated through the blood
so then that one becomes red so half of
your body that's where your veins are
blue and some of those just blue red
you're welcome which kind of like this
actually it's blue and red going back
and forth which color is the vein you
have to cut to diffuse it is it the
which one's blue and red is it the vein
of the artery veins are blue arteries
are red there it is
i hope you're right so
chicken heart is [ __ ] delicious which
is also why they tell you uh if you're
scuba diving and you get a cut
don't freak out when their blood comes
out and it's blue it's because it hasn't
touched oxygen over here oh that's crazy
a cut it's going to turn red immediately
immediately because it's getting
oxidized it comes out blue in the water
that's nice i don't have any dead blood
in the water from myself but whatever
any depths like yeah probably probably
like way lower
where you just can't there's no light
probably very little oxygen or something
don't be surprised if you can't see it
don't be surprised it's for sure blue
though
goes by your blood
illuminates it enough
so uh the world's first
heartless human was able to live without
a pulse wow well because they had a
pacemaker is that are you this is a
story about a marion where there's an
icebox
i enjoyed that i have an ice box where
my heart used to be there it is i love
omicron we having no pulse means that
they can't tell that your heart's
beating but your heart's beating right
well that's the thing beating uh in
terms of the pulse usually is because
it's pumping blood right yep however in
this situation i'll get into the details
there's no pump uh in order to make the
blood flow but they're making it flow so
in recent years modern medicine has
provided us with everything that we know
right but uh
in terms of hearts they've always tried
to make heart pumps and this time is the
first successful time that it wasn't
made as a pump that's crazy explain how
it works
they say after decades of trial and
error among surgeons desperately trying
to create a machine that wouldn't break
down or cause blood clots and infections
two doctors at the texas heart institute
developed a device that used whirling
rotors to pump blood around the body
without a heartbeat does that mean it's
better
it might be is it like more continuous
flow rather than like
but there has to be a trade-off though
these two doctors first tested the idea
in an eight month old calf called
abigail removing her heart and
successfully replacing it with two
centrifugal pumps which circulated the
blood through her by every metric we
have to analyze patients she's not
living technically because the heart's
not pumping but she was alive but if you
[ __ ] tickle her she's trying to laugh
and [ __ ] yeah so she's alive but
by a health and science concept it's
like not alive because no heartbeat
right there's no pulse yeah you don't
feel a pain there's no pulse but she's
technically warm for a [ __ ] extended
time so they get more ticklish because
of this
they get way more ticklish that's crazy
so they say after practicing on 38 after
practicing on 38 calves two doctors
progressed to human trials selecting a
55 year old man
called craig lewis who was suffering
from
amyloidosis a rare autoimmune disease
that causes a buildup of abnormal
proteins and in turn rapid heart kidney
and liver failure what does that mean so
lewis heart had become so damaged that
doctors gave him about 12 hours to live
so he's already gonna die imagine that
you just got there in time for hearing
[ __ ] let's do this at which point his
wife linda suggested something drastic
his wife linda said he wanted to live
and we didn't want to lose them you
never know how much time you have but it
was worth it i've been reading about
these cow hearts can you have one
so in march 2011 she approached these
two doctors who removed her husband's
heart and installed the artificial
device wow not a pacemaker no no it's a
centrifugal fugal flagger it's a rotary
system
it's like a pool filter so it looks like
this inside whoa whoa
that's nuts
looks like a tattoo it looks like the
that chucky cheese thing it vibrates and
you gotta hold hang on yeah
this is him post surgery just so you
have a face to a name he's alive he's a
live post surgery he looks like he's
made of wax yeah this is a wax
it was just a wax head that's a pretty
scary thing madame tassad
it's like that [ __ ] thing at the
front it's probably because of the
kidney failure too he's not filtering
all his the stuff good enough well post
uh operations she said i listened and it
was a hum which is amazing he didn't
have a pulse she said her husband who
worked for the city of houston
maintaining the city's uh vast system of
waste paper pumps would have appreciated
the pulseless heart cobbled together
from various materials
and the doctor explained uh dacron i
don't know the dacrim on the inside and
fiberglass impregnated in silicone on
the outside so it's pretty much a
moderate amount of homemade stuff that
puts like what that actual heart is
together
and he's alive but without a pulse now
that's crazy well it worked oh no when
it worked oh no
it didn't fail it worked successfully
however because of his uh autoimmune
deficiency his other organs failed and
then he eventually had to pass damn man
but that is pretty crazy
but that is still registered as the
first successful like heartless human
and so we're pretty much bridging
entering this age where the science and
technology is allowed
you know making what countries what
country is this in america dang imagine
the texas yeah the bill for that
well maybe it wasn't so much because if
it's a first human trial i'm guessing
there might be freebies
right because the second you're paying
for the service and they [ __ ] up dunzo
but if it's kind of like hey we need to
try this on a human so he's like you're
gonna die anyway so let's try this you
know what i'm saying but i don't know
maybe there still is a bill because
we're in america or maybe because you
already had four cert four surgeries on
his punch card he that was the fifth
surgery like like a boba place yeah he's
probably good you get this experimental
surgery for free after the surgery he
did wake up he began to recover he was
able to speak and sit up in the chair
but yeah
his condition i wonder how that affects
like if he starts exercising like what
happens with his heart like it's able to
to maintain that or i'm sure it would
yeah like how does it send signals back
and forth right like when you're
exercising and you and your body knows
it needs more oxygen and more nutrients
it'll pump harder yeah on purpose yeah
does it like
centrifuge [ __ ] heart i highly doubt
that this dude was getting up sprinting
to figure out he should try it though he
should have tried yeah tested it
my father-in-law has a pacemaker and he
he gets nervous while he's exercising or
doing really anything so how do how do
pacemakers work uh they put it inside of
your body and then it works i think it
keeps the electrical signal of your
heart does that firmware so anytime
that's the stupidest [ __ ] i've ever
heard about i think yeah technically
your heart works like a battery like
there's positive and negative ions and
it's the transfer of that through the
membranes that causes it to pump and
that's yeah that's what it looks like
when it starts to lose the positive ion
effect it's when they need to put the sa
node or some [ __ ] right so then if if
his heart needs a little boosty it like
does a charge and like actually just
like yeah that's why the like the
defibrillators defibrillators it's it's
electricity so so like the for the first
couple months he didn't he wasn't used
to that so all of a sudden his heart
would just go like zapping he's like
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] got it it just
jump starts the it needs a signal to
keep that is that like when like maybe
he was like
chilling and then suddenly everything
kind of like slowed down so it needed to
kind of bring it back up i have no idea
yeah it probably felt that this is
losing like the charge
also if it's low battery it just keeps
on hitting him until he replaces it oh
[ __ ] like a smoke alarm yeah
if you guys needed a new heart would you
get a new like one of these
defibrillators at this age yes
at this age i would anything to keep me
but if i'm like [ __ ] 80 i'm like [ __ ]
it i would i would need a couple more
human trials because like this guy he
managed
he did manage to live for more than a
month with a pulseless heart that's
that's pretty freaking and the doctors
man doctors were able to say the pumps
had worked flawlessly and the fact that
it was the other organs that failed on
them not the heart that's pretty so to
be the first human test that's like dude
do you think the heart's like dude i'm
putting the team in my [ __ ] back can
we [ __ ] pick it up somewhere else
yeah like it's like a group science
project this is [ __ ] up well the heart
already gave up it's already out
literally even a pacemaker still like on
a heart right yeah this new machine yeah
only [ __ ] machine which is like
that's that's a cyborg so if there were
replacements for every other organ that
failed
like there is for the heart which sounds
like that's the hardest one then he
technically could keep living right yeah
technically the future that we're moving
towards they're able to keep that
function of the blood flow robocop
houston reporting for duty he kind of
looked like the guy from [ __ ] world
cup i mean it's just probably going to
be like really really acceptable in a
kind of an exponential amount of time
because remember i'm assuming the first
time like hearing aids were invented or
some [ __ ] right that's crazy too or like
you see the videos nowadays where it's
like uh somebody who's been color blind
gets like these pair of glasses and they
see like color for the first time
yo those videos make me cry
just kidding
[Laughter]
they debunked it no some people were
faking them though no because my uh
my right hand man at barbell he is
colorblind so we got him that for
christmas
and then uh he please faking it for you
no he puts it on and he goes
so that's what grass looks like
and i was just like like you don't think
you were just colorblind you don't even
know what grass looks like
well his reds and his greens are nice
so grass looks red to him they look like
different shades of like gray
you know yeah sometimes colored blind
well there's layers to it there's like
colorblind there's like color
deficiencies right yeah yeah like you
saw a fire truck and he goes
oh that makes sense why it's that color
i knew that one can see it
you know just like a lot of things that
he did he started cheering because
there's just like a lot of things that
he didn't understand he had to jump to
his own conclusions now it's like i
understand why a lot of things are the
way they how expensive are those glasses
it wasn't that expensive and you saw
type this toys holy [ __ ] these things
are bright as [ __ ] it's not like
children's like primary colors that's so
this is crazy like oh my god my magna
hat's red
i thought it was green not gray i
thought it was great
[Music]
you